OF OPPORTUNITIES AROUND BOTH
THESE NE
AND PATIENCE BY KNIGHT.
AND THAT POINT SHOT BY OUR HEAD
UP WHEN HAGG ON THE ICE AND WIT
AGAINST MacKENZIE WEEGAR.
ALONG THE BOARDS FOR TA
LANDING.
CENTERING THIS EXPLOSIVE LINE
WITH DUCLAIR ENJOY HIST IS INTE.
AND JUST A GREAT PASS THERE BUP.
AND THAT'S A GOOD STOP BY PETR
RIGHT NOW, NYLANDER WILL TAKE A
AND THE GOOD QUICK STICK.
LYUBUSHKIN HERE LOSES HIS OTION
BLOCKED BY CHIAROT.
THE FRONT.
YOU SAW EARLIER THE DEFEF
GIROUX SENDING CROSS CREASE.
GUDAS FIRES AND THAT'S OFF AT.
>> Craig: HE BARELY GOT THAT
FOOT AGAINST THE POST.
IT ALMOST LOOKED LIKE, CHRIS, HE
ILL KEEP IT DOORSTEP.
REINHART FOLLOWS.D EYE CONTA
SLICK MOVE OFF HIS SKATE.
BUT UNABLE TO GETF YOUR OPPONEN.
DONE IT EIGHT TIMES WHEN
TRAILING, GOING INTO THE THIRD.
SO THE LEAFS CAN YOU PLAY THAT
BACK IN DEEP.
HOLL CHIPPED TO CENTRE.
AND THERE'S MARNER CATCHING UP
PULLS IT ACROSS.
NO PANIC.
BOARDS. ON.LATION INhris: SPENCE
GOOD STOP.
MRAZEK AND GOT IT.
HUBERDEAU, TRIES TO SET THINGS
THEIR FEET HERE FOR ARE GOING TO
HIGH-STICK.
AND IT WAS A FLORIDA HIGH-STICK
IN THE N N